This is a fake US $100 bill.
This is also a fake US $100 bill.
Which one is worse?
You might think that this fake bill is
worse than this fake bill because this
one's more obviously fake.
But wouldn't being more obviously fake
make it better, not worse?
Doesn't the fact that it's easier to
spot as a fake and therefore less likely
to deceive people
make it better,
not worse?
In other words,
what's worse about this fake bill?
It does a worse job at looking like an
authentic bill.
But this one isn't supposed to look like
an authentic bill. It's supposed to look
fake.
The color's all wrong. It has play money
and not legal tender on the front and
back.
The purpose of this bill is not to trick
anyone.
The purpose is to teach kids how money
works and what the different
denominations are or just for kids to
play with.
It's not made to deceive.
This fake bill was made to trick people.
Its purpose is to deceive you.
And the interesting thing about
counterfeits
is that the more authentic they look,
the more deceptive they are.
The more authentic this fake bill looks,
the more people it will deceive.
Here's a related thought.
The German philosopher Immanuel Kant
said, "The only thing that's good
without qualification
is a good will."
The only thing that's good without
qualification is a good will.
What does this mean?
Well, there are all kinds of things that
we typically think of as good, but
they're actually bad if they're attached
to an evil will.
So, they're not good without
qualification.
For instance, we would normally think of
intelligence as a good thing.
But what if this intelligence belongs to
a serial killer?
An intelligent serial killer who can use
his intelligence to conceal his crimes
and get away with killing more victims
is worse and more dangerous
than a dumb killer who makes mistakes
and gets caught.
Here's a list of the IQs of various
serial killers and murderers.
Not completely reliable numbers. Nathan
Leopold at the top had his IQ tested by
the military and they used a weird test.
Some of these are estimated, but the
point remains.
A lot of people who got away with
serious crimes got away with those
crimes because they were very
intelligent.
The world would have been a better place
if these killers had been dumber.
So, intelligence is ordinarily good, but
it's not good without qualification
because it can be bad if it's used for
evil.
What about charisma, the ability to
attract and influence people with charm
and magnetism?
Nick Fuentes has tons of charisma,
charisma falling out of his pockets, and
he's intelligent.
His charisma helps him become more and
more popular.
But what's that charisma attached to?
Hitler was a pedophile and kind of a
pagan. It's like, well, he was also
really [__] cool. So,
you know, time to grow up. Second
semester, you know, I got home in the
spring and I was like, "Mom, Dad, Hitler
was awesome. Hitler was right. And the
Holocaust didn't happen." That is how
those 6 million cookies come crumbling
apart
and go up the chimney at the cookie
baking factory at the Chips Ahoy
headquarters. My favorite song is Heil
Hitler. My favorite song is gas
chambers. Hitler alone stood against the
communists on one side, the communist
Jews on the one side, the capitalist
Jews on the other, literally a two-front
war. Dude, Hitler had aura. You know
what I have to say about that? Hitler
had aura. Aura. Riding down the street
like this.
And everybody's like, "Polish people
have this bad habit of like hating
Hitler." And we just we're going to stop
dissing the Nazis all the time, okay?
So, his charisma helps him win support
for seriously evil ideas. The world
would be a better place if people like
Nick lacked charisma.
Think about speaking ability or
preaching ability, the ability to
mesmerize crowds and make them think
deeply about spiritual matters.
More than two decades ago, I was driving
down the road near campus with Nabeel
and I played a tape of Ravi Zacharias
for him. This was when Nabeel was still
a Muslim.
He listened to Ravi for a few minutes
and said,
"This guy is the perfect communicator."
But as we all found out much, much
later, Ravi was using his abilities to
lure in victims and to shield himself
from scrutiny.
His abilities helped him manipulate and
deceive and abuse people.
So, those abilities were not good
without qualification.
What about Bible knowledge?
Surely knowledge of the Bible is good.
Imagine the ultimate Bible teacher,
someone who knows the Old Testament and
New Testament from memory in Hebrew,
Aramaic, and Greek.
Suppose he knows every commentary that's
ever been written backwards and
forwards. He knows what every rabbi and
every church father said about every
passage and he can answer any question
you have about any passage in the Bible.
Sounds good, right?
What if he uses that knowledge to start
a cult with him at the center of the
universe?
No one would be able to correct or
refute him because he would use his
immense knowledge to justify anything he
said or any behavior, no matter how
depraved.
Who could stand against him?
Now for something everyone wants,
something that has to be good. Surely
it's always good to have
a following.
Think about Candace Owens and Tucker
Carlson.
Candace has one of the biggest podcasts
on the planet, sometimes the biggest.
But she comes across
as a bit unhinged.
Every person who speaks about Israel has
to basically say a statement that's
like, you know, I don't want to get
killed.
Like like literally, you know, speaking
about people are like, "Candace, beef up
your security."
Excuse my language, but like that is not
normal, okay? The way that you get
comfortable with it is you're like,
"Well, you know, they shot JFK in an
open car, so there's not I mean, he's a
sitting president. I mean, obviously it
doesn't my security doesn't really
matter. If they want me, they're going
to get me. I just want to be clear.
Anything happens to me, blame the
Zionists. Like 1,000% blame the
Zionists.
Let that be what my parting words, okay?
Like Andrew Tate said something that
really stuck with me. He was just like,
you know, at the end of the day,
they're just going to rape your kids
last. Guess what?
It's good that she comes across as a bit
unhinged because that's a warning sign
to lots of people.
Candace can still get a huge crowd
watching because she's drawing viewers
from the entire world. And there are
tons of people in the world who are
really into conspiracy theories.
But people who aren't just dying to hear
Candace's latest conspiracy theory
have been walking away from the lunacy.
You don't get to ask those questions.
What's wrong with you, Mom? Why you so
scared? They're getting sick of it and
losing interest.
So, Candace will lead a lot of people to
some completely deranged ideas, but she
would actually be more dangerous if she
didn't come across as crazy to so many
people.
In other words,
there are people who stopped watching
Candace. They say, "I used to love
Candace.
I had to stop watching because she's so
unhinged."
But it's actually good that she's so
unhinged because if she wasn't, she'd be
deceiving even more people.
Her dangerous ideas would be harder to
spot.
This is why Tucker Carlson is actually
more dangerous than Candace.
Tucker still speaks at huge conservative
events. Tucker spoke at Charlie Kirk's
memorial.
And there's always one guy with a bright
idea and I could just hear him say,
"I've got an idea. Why don't we just
kill him?
That'll shut him up.
That'll fix the problem."
Why do we see Tucker at these events,
but not Candace?
Because Tucker seems less crazy.
He's less crazy, so he's less of a risk
and less of a threat.
He's much safer, so he can speak at all
the events.
That's weird to me because I see things
the exact opposite. The crazier someone
is,
the less dangerous he seems to me
because he's easier to spot.
I can't imagine Kanye doing too much
damage because everyone knows Kanye is
crazy.
Tucker, by contrast, is going to lead a
lot more conservatives and a lot more
Christians down a horrible path because
they trust him.
He doesn't come at you screaming like a
lunatic. He nudges.
He slowly nudges day after day, week
after week, until you're heading in a
completely different direction and you
can't even figure out how or why you
changed course.
There are endless examples here, but
let's go with an easy one.
In 2025, Tucker's been slowly convincing
his followers that Islam is good and
that Sharia isn't nearly as bad as its
critics claim.
He's like, "You know what Islam means?
It's submission."
And like let it hang in the air like
that was self-evidently disgusting and I
was like I kind of think submission to
God is like the whole point of life, but
I didn't say anything. I was like
I'm I'm I don't think I'm against that,
actually.
But you should know, Seth, that the real
danger is Sharia law.
Sharia law. And you can tell when you go
to a place like Abu Dhabi or Riyadh,
like, "Oh, man, I hope we don't ever
wind up in a society like this
with a rape rate of zero, where you
leave your keys in your Lamborghini and
don't ever worry about it being stolen
and
you know, if people want to get wasted,
they do it at home. You know what I
mean? Yeah, I I don't
>> Oh, boy, I hope we don't wind up with
that. When people complain about the
treatment of women and girls in
Afghanistan, where little girls are
being married off to much older men and
girls can't go to school past the age of
12, so they don't learn to think, and
women can't even speak or show their
faces outside their homes,
Tucker mocks the concerns.
The Taliban, we hear so much about the
Taliban's oppression of women and making
music illegal, and they do those things.
However,
>> understood why I was supposed to give a
[__] about that. I mean, I I want
everyone to be free just as a matter of
principle, but that didn't Whether
people can, you know, girls can get PhDs
in
feminist studies or whatever is of less
concern to me, right? Why should we care
if women can't get PhDs in feminist
studies?
Is that what anyone was complaining
about?
Look, if you want to say, "Hey,
it's not our country. We don't control
the rest of the world, so let's stay out
of it."
That's one thing.
But to pretend that what's going on with
women and girls in Afghanistan is just a
bunch of whining about not being able to
get doctorates in gender studies,
and to get conservatives and Christians
to see the situation that way,
that seems completely, utterly, totally
evil to me.
But conservatives and Christians will
slowly warm up to Islamic law because
Tucker is going to slowly, gently nudge
them in that direction.
He's going to deceive more people
because he's much more careful about it.
So, bad qualities attached to an evil
will can actually be good in a weird way
because they can help you spot the evil.
Good qualities attached to an evil will
are bad.
All right.
Have we learned anything yet?
Let's find out.
Pop quiz.
If the devil comes up to you right now,
what's he going to say?
Is he going to say
A, "Hi, I'm the devil and I want to
bring you and everyone around you to
hell."
or B, "Hi, I'm your greatest ally.
You're very special to me. I want the
best for you, so know that you can
always trust me. Let's work together and
change the world. Now, let me tell you
who your real enemies are."
What's the devil going to say?
The answer, obviously, is B. He'll claim
to be your greatest ally.
The goal of counterfeiter isn't simply
to make a fake bill. This is a fake
bill. You can make one of these on your
printer.
The goal of a counterfeiter is to make a
bill that looks and feels as much like
an authentic bill as possible.
And the more the counterfeit bill looks
and feels like an authentic bill,
the more deceptive it is.
So, don't be blinded by intelligence or
knowledge or charisma or the number of
followers someone has.
Always look
for the goodwill.
[Music]